grab onto your snake monsters it's the
end of the world and the end of
Netflix's Ragnarok which after three
seasons has completed its run with an
ending that is currently sitting at a
4.3 out of 10 and with good reason in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into ragnarok's series finale and why
it's sure to get fans up in arms now
let's get into it the final episode
starts a bit weird since everything is
pretty much perfect in the Sleepy town
of Etta Magna along with the other gods
decides to defy fate and instead of
plunging the world into a final battle
between gods and Giants offers peace in
exchange youthful Industries the company
run by the Giants must make efforts to
be more environmentally friendly after
accusations that their plant cause
different types of cancer to the
townsfolk in episode 1 we meet an
electrician named merits who got liver
cancer working at the factory and in
season 2 you may remember grie's father
was diagnosed with cancer as well so
when we start the final episode
everything seems to be going well
Lawrence's giant snake which plagued the
Fjord has gone off to sea woton has
given up drinking and a sense of calm
has returned to town but this piece
comes at a price it seems everyone has
moved on with their lives but our
protagonist Magna who is essentially the
second coming of Thor doesn't have
anything to protect anymore he's lost
his girlfriend and is unsure what
direction his life is taking all his
friends seem to have their lives
together saxa has taken over as head of
util Industries lortz is moving out with
his boyfriend Fior has found a new love
interest it has got her own reality TV
career and Harry is a gold medal
paralympian so how are you going to have
an epic finale where everything is
seemingly perfect this leads us to
ragnarok's controversial ending which in
my opinion was one of the biggest
cop-outs I've seen in a show in a long
time at their graduation ceremony Magna
watches as he and his friends receive
their diplomas conveniently right
outside Harry teaches a group of
disabled people all sorts of Olympic
sports as part of giving back to the
community he even throws a ball at a
woman with a broken neck
among this group is a kid with an eye
patch who in episode 4 was brutally hit
with an arrow through the eye how he
survived this I don't know well his
archery skills suck and he fumbles
hurtling the arrow through the
graduation ceremony and killing Jens
Lawrence's boyfriend Jens is the
manifestation of balder and it is said
that his death will signal the beginning
of Ragnarok this triggers the end of the
world and we see an all-out battle
between the gods and Giants but the
graduation ceremony continues Magna is
simultaneously seeing the world come to
an end but also takes part in his
graduation intercut in this segment are
scenes where magnet cleans out his room
and stumbles upon old Thor comics comics
which depict events we've already seen
in the show well I guess this is where I
just come out and say it pretty much
everything in this show was all in
magna's head all the magic and fun was a
psychological construct to protect Magna
from the trauma of his past this all
seems to have started in season one with
the death of esold who if you turn on
the closed captioning is the one who
narrates much of the final episode if
you remember back to the beginning of
the show Magna was already dealing with
the uncertainty of moving to a new town
following the traumatic loss of his
father the death of his new friend esold
created a fantasy world in which he
could live out an epic battle between
gods and Giants based on the comics he
obsessed over in reality it was a
defense mechanism to keep his mind
occupied from the pain of losing those
he loved at the beginning of the episode
we're given this title card that refers
to the nine steps stating in Ragnarok
Thor meets The midgard Serpent and gets
bitten by its poisonous teeth with its
venom in his blood Thor only has nine
steps left to step in this world near
the end of the episode bangna does
indeed get bitten by this serpent but
his nine steps are a metaphor for him
letting go of the fantasy world and
stepping into the real one zigni Magnus
girlfriend understands that he's been
traumatized and detached from reality
yet still wants to give their
relationship another chance Magna takes
those nine steps collapsing in front of
her signifying his leap from one world
to another and if that wasn't enough we
see him getting rid of those Comics that
influenced his fantasy the final scene
shows Magnum meeting up with his friends
as they are all alive and they enjoy
drinks together that is of course
without esoldt who did actually die way
back in season one she tells Magna that
she'll always be with him as the series
comes to an end this was a major letdown
for me to find out that basically
everything was in his head seems like
such a lazy way to end what was
otherwise a pretty imaginative show but
this ending also leaves us with many
unanswered questions what of what we saw
was real and what was in his head
honestly I'm frustrated because more
than anything this show deserved better
but what did you think of the final
season of Ragnarok I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at story YT until next
time remember